blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman i hate
to have to start here today
but i have a sort of um epidemiological
gun to my head for uh metaphorical
purposes
called the delta variant and called
anti-vaxxerism
and it's just bad news about this
pandemic that we just
can't seem to shake thanks to people
refusing to get vaccinated
and thanks to the highly contagious
delta variant average daily cases
here in the united states are up 122
in just over three weeks more than
doubling
in just three weeks up from their bottom
of about 12 000 cases a day we had
gotten down
to about 12 000 cases a day by the way
still more than the 10 000 case
per day mark that dr anthony fauci
established over a year ago as sort of
like
we need to get below that to say it's
under control we almost got down to that
and now cases back
up 122 to about 27 000 a day this
is really quick and it's because of the
rapidly spreading
60 more contagious delta variant
combined
with too many people just choosing not
to get vaccinated there's vaccines
everywhere they're coming out
they're you you can't walk through a
pharmacy without
just stumbling over vaccines and
um 20 of the country just not interested
and the good news is and we'll get back
to this if you are vaccinated
you are really well protected against
the delta variant if you are vaccinated
and you get the virus in one of these
what are called breakthrough infections
you're likely not to have symptoms and
if you do have a symptomatic vaccinated
case
it's likely not to be serious you're not
likely to be hospitalized you're not
likely to die but nothing is perfect
everything is bell curve distribution
and some vaccinated people
who do everything right will get sick
and they will die
and every person who chooses not to get
vaccinated makes that
more likely we wondered though cases are
up
but will deaths be up because with so
many people vaccinated we might see
cases but we won't see deaths go up
we said three weeks ago we need three
weeks to answer that question because
deaths lag cases by three weeks and
sadly the answer there is yes as well
you have to look carefully because it's
still a small
uptick in terms of raw numbers but on a
percentage basis
deaths are now up almost 20 percent
deaths per day in the u.s from kovid
bottomed out about a week ago
at 218 per day they have ticked back
up 20 to 259 per day
we have only fully vaccinated about half
of the united states
if you look at vaccinations per day you
see it
that we are now back down to the daily
vaccination levels
of early january when we had almost no
vaccine availability
we're now doing a pathetic flaccid
weak 500 000 doses a day
we have all the vaccines you can just
walk in almost anywhere
and we're only doing 500 000 doses a day
and since many of those are
parts of a two dose regimen we're really
only
completing a vaccination protocol for
probably about 350 000
people per day 0.1 of the population per
day
it's humiliating it's pathetic and the
virus is spreading it's not some
abstract thing oh
vaccinations are down but it has no real
impact case is up 122
deaths up almost 20 percent not just
happening in the u.s although it's
particularly bad here
globally cases are now back up
31 from their low globally
deaths are now back up about 3 percent
from their low remember deaths
follow cases by three to four weeks
nearly half of republicans
in the united states just don't want the
vaccine
people in other countries are falling
all over themselves to try to get the
limited vaccines that are available
and in the united states nearly half of
republicans say nah i don't want to go
and get it
it's horrifying stuff dr eric topel who
has been a guest on the program before
posted to his twitter
there are places in the united states
with vaccination rates
as low as 15 1-5
newton missouri 16 vaccination
douglas 15 reynolds 15
this is unconscionable now if there is
any good news we'll go back to something
i mentioned at this at the top of the
segment
it is once again the reassurance
that the vaccines work really well
we can't control the fact that even as
vaccinated people
we are more at risk thanks to people who
refuse to get vaccinated that we can't
we can't directly control we can try to
convince them but we can't change the
math of that
but being able to get vaccinated oneself
is a big piece because the latest
numbers are that
99 of those
who are currently hospitalized are
unvaccinated people so
the level of protection that you can
unilaterally give yourself
just by going and getting getting
vaccinated is absolutely huge
it's not perfect but it's absolutely
huge and that's the reassuring thing
the hope would be and this is
you know depending on whether you look
at pfizer or moderna
and you look at it there's a lot of
details in this the hope would be
maybe by the end of fall by winter
maybe not until early 2022 the vaccine
that will be available will be one that
is already tailored
for the delta variant but as we know
the more it spreads the more opportunity
to mutate and to go to some new variant
that the vaccine will not be tailored to
there's now talk of this lambda variant
from australia we don't know much about
it there's the possibility that it's
even more contagious than delta
we don't know about the mortality rate
these are all questions and because we
don't have answers to those questions
what question do we have an answer to
right now well the question is
how can you give yourself drastic
protection
and protect others it's just you go and
get vaccinated it's that simple
so it's depressing i'm not gonna lie it
is very very depressing
but um it is where we are today
and uh hopefully we will be able to
accelerate vaccination i don't know what
it'll take at this point i know that a
third of those who say i don't want it
say
if it's rece if it receives full
approval from the fda
i will go and get vaccinated one-third
of those who don't currently want the
vaccine say
i will get it if it gets full full uh
authorization full approval from the fda
that's coming soon so we will soon see
if we are going to see that
okay senate democrats are
to propose federal cannabis
decriminalization for many people one of
the
top issues of the joe biden campaign
was the full decriminalization of
cannabis of marijuana
at the federal level as a starting point
for hopefully eventual rescheduling
further legalization remember
decriminalization and legalization are
two different things and we'll talk
about
the impact of that actually on
tomorrow's program so
it's not legalization that we're talking
about but it is still a really really
big deal
uh cnbc reporting senate majority leader
chuck schumer proposed legislation to
legalize marijuana
at the federal level the cannabis
administration
and opportunity act would remove
marijuana from the controlled substances
act
and introduce regulations to tax
cannabis products now even the article
is not exactly right
because the proposal is for
decriminalized which is in the headline
but then the point says legalize
that's not actually what the proposal is
it would also expunge
federal records of non-violent cannabis
offenders this is a huge deal this was
proposed yesterday
and the idea here is start laying the
groundwork
to ease legislation that
while it may not in the way that it is
written disproportionately target
uh poor people and people of color in
practice that's what the war on drugs
has done
and we know because we've heard from the
people who were involved in the creation
of the current infrastructure we have
around uh the criminality of drugs that
that was actually the goal the war on
drugs was
a i mean i i sort of want to say
racially tinged but that's not really
strong enough
it was a racially targeted reaction
to the civil rights movement that
started in the late 50s and and sort of
made more progress
during the 1960s in the united states um
the proposal the cannabis administration
and opportunity act
would remove marijuana from the
controlled substances act and introduce
regulations
to cannabis products the proposal would
expunge
federal records of non-violent cannabis
offenders
and allow people serving time in federal
prison importantly federal not state
for non-violent marijuana crimes to
petition a
court for resentencing the plan would
also
create an opportunity trust fund
from new cannabis tax revenue in order
to invest
in programs for communities most
affected
by the quote failed war on drugs
according to a draft of the bill
now what what is the probability of this
becoming law
the plan to decriminalize marijuana will
likely face
a contentious battle in the senate as
it's generally opposed by republicans
and some moderate democrats and has not
received an endorsement from president
joe biden
schumer will require 60 votes including
at least 10 gop
votes to pass it through the senate in
terms of what we've seen on legalization
and decriminalization so far
so far 37 states and dc have legalized
medical cannabis eights the 18 states
and dc
have legalized recreational use but it
is still
illegal under federal law public polling
shows that nearly 70 percent of
americans support legalizing the drugs
so there's a bunch of stories here one
story is
is joe biden going to after what he
talked about during his campaign
come out and endorse this particular
bill as many of you know
in politics often you campaign on
supporting an idea
and then when a bill is put forth that
would make that idea a reality
oftentimes politicians will say well
this particular bill as written has this
problem has that problem and
remains to be seen whether joe where joe
biden is going to land on this
particular bill
number two we have talked increasingly
over the years
about how in the united states the
policy
desires of the american people as a
whole
often don't get made a reality and this
is this is for a number of different
reasons
one reason is that our elected officials
are far more conservative than the
population at large if you look
at sort of the average political
placement on the spectrum
of uh at the federal level senators and
members of congress and you compare
their
their positions on policy to those of
the
american people for example 70 support
legalization and yet we don't even know
that we can get 60
of the senate to say yeah i'll vote for
this bill that's one issue that we've
talked about as well so there's a number
of different
stories here and we know that uh
um and elites and the wealthy
have outsized influence on what actually
becomes law and what the legislative
priorities are relative to just the
average person
one stunning example of this is of
course after the sandy hook
school shooting during barack obama's
presidency which was now
many years i don't even know the number
of years it's way more it feels way more
recent than it actually is
there was like 88 90 support for what's
called universal background checks among
the american people in the united states
and yet democrats who at the time
controlled the white house the house and
the senate
were not able to get universal
background checks made into law and
there's a ton of different reasons for
why that is and all of them corrosive
to the idea of a representative
democracy but that's one example
the american people's view now on
cannabis the at minimum
decriminalization
um is another example here's an
opportunity good for chuck schumer for
putting forth the bill
but we will see where it actually goes
on august 16th
it is the 16th speaking of it feels like
yesterday
it is the 16th anniversary of the david
pakman show
um and we will be doing a one day huge
membership special
16 it's going to be related to the
number 16 because it is the 16th
anniversary of the show
that's on monday august 16th
if you would like to be notified of this
historic it's an historic
and a historic opportunity to sign up
for a membership
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com and then monday morning
that's monday august 16th you'll get an
email telling you how to sign up let's
take a quick break
what a packed show we have for you today
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist
and what they do is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that our show does depend in a
real way
on folks like you who sign up for
memberships on our website and we do
produce an extra entire show for our
members you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and use the coupon code
better21 to get a discount if you
so please the the normal prices are very
very good
uh but i am glad to offer an even bigger
discount with the code better21 which
you can use at joinpackman.com
the david pakman show subreddit now has
nearly 32
000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed and participating and
you can propose uh segments for the show
you can engage with other people please
don't troll though we do have moderators
and we're trying to keep the trolling
down to a very very dull roar
a few posts that i do want to signal
that i found interesting a bunch of
different people
posting links to articles about the 30
year old anti-vaccine
nurse who got covered and died and
i i'm glad to report on it and a lot of
people have asked me to talk about it
but the glee with which some
people are saying she got what she
deserved it's really tough for me to get
on board with that because
i see these people as victims these are
people who fell
for anti-science right-wing propaganda
it's hard to cheer that and the the the
truth is
i would rather her still be alive and
even if you don't care about
this one individual um think about the
greater good we
we would still all be better how many
people might she have spread the virus
to
in eventually dying from it even if it
was based on her decision not to get
vaccinated because of her beliefs
um we're all better off if she gets
vaccinated
and doesn't get sick and doesn't risk
passing it to others so whether your
motivations are
moral or societal
or for other people or even economic
because we know of the huge economic
cost
for me i'm just not where i know some of
the audience is
in a sort of like total disregard and
lack of empathy for this woman also
as far as we know i mean statistically
she probably has
some loved ones who did get vaccinated
and did do everything right and now they
suffer as a result of her death as well
so
listen i get it at a certain point
there's it's personal responsibility and
you have to decide and
we can't force anyone to understand
or accept the science about vaccines but
i'm not where some people in the
audience are
in terms of the total disregard lack of
empathy and sometimes almost glee
about the fact that an anti-vaxxed
person died i mean that's a trag that is
the tragedy right that's what we're
talking about
um 99 of those who are now hospitalized
are not vaccinated this has a very real
impact but yes
an anti-vaccine nurse who was only 30
years old
did get the virus and died another post
related to vaccination
about how the cpac crowd over the
weekend we covered cpac earlier in the
week
the cpac crowd cheered as vaccination
rates
were announced to not be that high and
this user pointing out that the
republican party is really the pro-death
party
and saying at this point i don't even
have any long-winded explanation beyond
the title what more needs to be said
vaccination rates aren't meeting joe
biden's projected goals yay
that hurts biden and it helps us the
republican party
and it means a lot more people are going
to die needlessly
and so they cheer that was one of the
most disgusting moments of cpac
cheering the fact that there are
millions of people
in the united states who by choice are
choosing not to protect themselves and
by extension
protect the people around them from
coronavirus and as i said before
i i am angry at them to some degree
because it's infuriating what they're
doing
they also are victims of the fact that
they've
fallen for stuff that's not true they've
fallen for it
from the republican party they've fallen
for it from the so-called libertarians
talking about medical freedom as if
that's even remotely what this is about
they've fallen for the conspiracies they
are victims it doesn't mean we can't be
mad at them
but they are victims and i think it's
important not to forget that to some
degree
lastly someone pointed out that what's
up with david's pen
and they wrote that sometimes my hands
come into the frame
and i have nothing in my hands and
sometimes i've got a sharpie in my left
hand
and then sometimes i have a sharpie in
my right hand and then sometimes it's a
pen
in the left hand and then all of a
sudden the pen is in my right there is
no rhyme or reason
at different points during the show i
may make a note on my
extensive legal pads that i have just
off screen uh sometimes i may use the
sharpie to cross something out once i've
made
a statement about it on the show
something i think about
there's really no rhyme or reason to it
and i apologize if it's distracting to
people
that oh and even that noise may have
been distracting to people
um i am not trying to do anything other
than stay on track
and present to you all the information
that i intend to
join the discussion on issues ranging
from importance
uh at the bottom end about my sharpie
use all the way to the top end about
people who are choosing not to get
vaccinated
you can find the subreddit at
davidpakman.com reddit
this next clip is truly a pleasure to
watch
and it is exactly what i have been
recommending be done
when dealing with right wing media
engage in conversation
but get them on the record did trump win
or lose in 2020
let's start there just so we know who
and what we're dealing with here
the daily beast reports that yesterday
during an appearance on fox news
i'm sorry the day before yesterday texas
state uh
representative james talarico a democrat
young guy challenged pete hegseth
to tell his viewers that donald trump
lost the 2020 presidential election to
joe biden
heg seth refused to just confirm
yes trump lost which really proves
the guest's point in trying to get him
on the record about this
and talarico quickly started going after
fox news
he eventually demanded hey pete say that
trump lost
say it let's take a look at it this is
just
fantastic someone in your district that
can't get identification
you have made a lot of money personally
and you've enriched a lot of
corporations with advertising by getting
on here and spewing
lies and conspiracy theories to folks
who trust me about money so what i'm
asking you to do is
tell your voters right now that donald
trump hey
that is resolved the lie that is did
democrats
account for voter
real quick can you answer the question
did donald trump i think the election is
running questions i'm not
don't is this uncomfortable so i think
he
i think he said he said they're meant to
say i'm asking questions not answering
them
but he's he seems so tripped up question
for you no it's because this is the
the three my question is why are you in
washington dc and not in
someone he's in washington d.c because
texas republicans
threatened texas democrats with arrest
with arrest
if they didn't show up in order to
prevent a quorum
in order to prevent a disgusting texas
voter suppression bill from from passing
but as far as the clip goes
i just absolutely love that every
democratic
guest should be doing that every time
they appear on these networks but but
oh but david sir they're not being
brought on to talk about whether trump
once so it's sandbagging it's wrong for
them to do
i don't care make them kick you off make
them never
invite you back if every single
democratic guest starts asking this
it's going to very quickly put them in a
really awkward position but like i've
been saying
do this in every interview with
republican officials as well
when whoever on whatever channel
interviews a republican official ask
them
just for context did donald trump win or
lose the 2020 election
and many of them have figured out how to
play coy many of them you say
did trump win the election or did trump
lose the election and they would say
listen joe biden is the president of the
united states that's what matters
because what they're
what they're avoiding answering is
whether joe biden
should be based on the election results
that's how they play coy with it and so
even asking the question the host still
is going to have to be prepared
but i think that this is an important
thing to do because at the end of the
day
what's the point of interviewing people
when they can't even be on the same page
about basic facts
would we trust them about any of their
views on politics
if they can't even acknowledge who won
the 2020 election
think about it analogously if we did a
series on space travel
and i suspect that a guest believed the
earth was flat
and i start the interview by saying is
the earth flat or
or spherical and they won't answer why
would i keep talking about space travel
with that person
and the interview they can't have we
can't even get to a simple foundational
uh infrastructure about just the
fundamentals of how the world works why
would i continue talking about space
travel and similarly in political
interviews
do you accept that donald trump
genuinely not because of
fraud or fraud just he just lost if you
don't accept that why are we going
to talk to you about your views on
politics it's a simple screening
question
really nicely done by james talarico i
hope
i hope that this becomes a trend where
democratic guests will say this to
right-wing hosts
and hosts will act ask republican guests
did trump win or did trump lose answer
that question before we move on i would
love to see it and we'll have more on
this strategy
on the david pakman show instagram which
you can find
at david pakman's show this is crazy but
nearly a hundred thousand followers on
the david pakman show instagram
we'll take a quick break and be back
with much more after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome bob kutner to the
program today who is co-editor of the
american prospect magazine
also chair at the heller school for
social policy and management
at brandeis university i really
appreciate your time today thanks for
being on
pleasure to be with you so i've been
interested in in the idea of economic
nationalism for some time
and one of the i guess where we can
maybe start is whether there is some
inconsistency among some on the left on
this issue because
i'm still developing sort of my my sense
of this but
there is a sort of uh global
egalitarianism
that i see from many who like me
describe themselves as being on the left
and progressives
that seems to stop short when it comes
to well we should have an economy that
prioritizes
the american worker we should have trade
deals that are best for
the united states is there a conflict
or an inconsistency there not
necessarily and i think it's it's really
important to start out by defining what
we mean
and i think economic nationalism means
two different things that sometimes get
uh conflated rather sloppily so good
let's start with that
please so if you are a roosevelt
progressive
and you're not a neo-liberal and you
think that
capitalism is predatory and in order to
have a system that is efficient and
socially just the government has to be
involved big time a democratic
government has to be involved big time
in regulating capitalism
that means that you have to put limits
on globalism
because if you have what we've had for
the past 30 or 40 years with wto
and the use of trade deals to undercut
the regulation of capitalism
you can't regulate capitalism i mean
banks can go offshore
and uh we don't care whether
products that we import are made with
slave labor you you know the whole
litany
sure so economic nationalism in one
sense of the word
simply means that we have to regulate
capitalism
and we for better or worse is the nation
state there's no global economy
you can't regulate uh capitalism with
the republic of nafta
you have to regulate it with the united
states of america where where i'm a
citizen and you're a citizen and to some
degree is that also just the
practicality of
uh legal framework and and and just sort
of the the limits of what
any one group can do i mean i know we
have we have nato we have w
you know we have these organizations but
does it get sloppy
well it's about sovereignty yeah if you
want to try and regulate capitalism
you you need a degree of sovereignty and
the state is sovereign
um and uh there is no sovereignty
globally except to the extent that you
have treaties right
the other kind of economic nationalism
of which trump is the extreme example
or maybe hitler's the more extreme
example is
america first or germany first and screw
the rest of the world
and so where it gets tricky is on the
question of how you
make it possible for the whole world to
regulate capitalism
in the interest of ordinary people and
since we don't have a global government
that means you have to have agreements
you have to have treaties this morning's
new york times reports that
the eu is gonna have climate tariffs
if you if you try to export stuff uh
into the eu that
are made with processes and products
that pollute
you're going to have to pay a tariff now
that's a good kind of nationalism
and biden's talking about doing the same
thing
so the tricky part for me anyway
because i'm you know i'm a third world
guy as well as a new dealer
how do you extend this so that the whole
world is able to regulate predatory
capitalism
and interestingly um that is what was
attempted in 1944 at the bretton woods
conference
where the architect of that conference
was john maynard keynes he got a do-over
uh you know they got it wrong at the
treaty of versailles in
uh in 1919 where he was a junior
economic adviser to the british
government he
quit and discussed in protest and then
25 years later
he was the chair of the bretton woods
conference and he said
we have to orchestrate the rules of the
global system
so that every country gets to regulate
capitalism
in the interests of workers in the
interest of citizens
now here's the tricky part you get down
to cases
so if we think that china is predatory
we we think that china violates human
rights we think that china
violates the rules of the trading system
where they subsidize and they
dump and they uh steal intellectual
property and all that stuff
and um so we're going to have some
we're going to have an industrial policy
and we're going to have a national
security policy where
certain technologies we're not going to
allow china to acquire
that seems pretty sensible to have an
industrial policy where do you draw the
line
and is that an industrial policy for the
united states or is that an industrial
policy that the eu
and all of the democracies are part of
and then if that's the case
um who gets the business so for instance
um there are three major chip companies
that are not chinese that make
state-of-the-art ships
one's intel the other two are european
ericsson and nokia
so do you have a cartel do you carve up
the market
or do you say we have one set of rules
for companies that
play by you know democratic norms and
and market norms and a different set of
rules for china which doesn't play by
market norms
so where it gets tricky is around the
edges
where when you get down to cases and
here's vietnam
a third world country
a dictatorship but not as nasty a
dictatorship as china
and um a lot of stuff gets outsourced to
vietnam
by american companies and these are very
poor people who need the work
this is where it gets tricky and uh
so you have to have trade agreements
that are very different from the kind of
trade agreements that clinton and obama
made
that have human rights in them that have
some concern for the ability of third
world countries to get
a foot on the ladder so that they can
have decent living standards for their
for their people
but not simply turning the world over to
multinational corporations
yes and i wanted to i mean let's talk a
little bit about trade if we can because
um the the the concept of free trade
being a net positive is rooted in some
pretty traditional economic ideas of
specialization and relative efficiencies
of of
producing and exporting products and it
really goes back to a lot of that
that traditional economics uh and
at at the end of the day as you're
pointing out sometimes the best way
to control conditions when it comes to
labor
and products and imports is you bring
the you bring the supply lines domestic
uh but at the same time then you're
depriving
as you point out a lot of people around
the world
uh of the ability to better themselves
and better better their economic
situation so how how would how should we
interpret all of that and sort of parse
it yeah let me address what you said
about
trade being efficient and then let me
respond to the second question
yeah well here's a conundrum you know
david ricardo
etc uh theory of comparative advantage
yep
trade is efficient because of
specialization okay but hold on
we have known ever since roosevelt and
before really
that free markets are not efficient
right markets price things wrong
markets priced carbon wrong
lord nicholas turns said global climate
change is history's
epic case of market failure right
markets price labor wrong because
corporations have the power to really
exploit workers
markets price all kinds of stuff wrong
they price housing wrong
um so question how is it that
we need to have a managed form of
capitalism domestically
because markets price things wrong and
then somehow when you cross borders
all of a sudden markets price things
right and the answer is they don't
and um this gets into power
relationships
uh you you want third world countries to
be able to
uh get jobs and and gain market share
but
you don't want them to exploit their
workers so let me give you an example of
a trade deal that i think was a pretty
good trade deal yeah
um there used to be something called the
multi-fiber agreement
it was a worldwide cartel for textiles
and apparel
and the idea was that um we're going to
give every
country that wants to export uh textile
products into the united states
a quota and the economist said this is
terrible this is a cartel this violates
the free market and the other side of
the argument was well if you if you just
eliminate it china will get everything
because china will underprice everybody
and all these other countries will get
the short end of the stick common
argument
huh commonly heard commonly repeated yes
so what they did for a while this was in
the last two years of clinton when bob
rice was secretary of labor
and actually had some influence they
made
they made an agreement cambodia was the
model country
and the agreement was if if you follow
uh international labor organization
norms
and you give workers the right to
organize
we will give you uh additional uh
quota slots uh under the multi-fiber
arrangement
um and so thanks to that
the labor movement got a foothold in
cambodia
and workers actually started being paid
better it didn't hurt their market share
it helped their market share
and then of course the republicans come
in and they just blow away the whole
thing
so there's a middle ground i guess this
is my punchline yeah
there's a middle ground between
absolutely free trade which is a mirage
anyway
and um trumpian economic nationalism
which is a kind of negotiated trade
where you have some norms where you have
some standards
and the standards are not just a covert
way of screwing the third world
and a lot of the third world diplomats
have made the argument
that the west is hypocritical the west
uh
talks about the international labor
organization talks about labor standard
that's just protectionist and again you
got to get down to cases
depending on the particular rules that
are negotiated it can be protectionist
or it can be in the interest of workers
everywhere so you have the case of the
bangladesh
horrible bangladesh fires where this is
a very
poor country the job
so that workers don't die in fires but
you don't do that as a covert way of
depressing your market share
you've got to get down to cases i guess
that's the point the last thing i wanted
to touch on briefly
relates to the coronavirus pandemic
we've talked to economists social
psychologists all sorts of different
folks about
uh the impacts that they see as a result
of the coronavirus pandemic and what
we've sort of learned
learned from it when it comes to an
economic nationalism perspective
globalization supply chains etc what do
you see as the big takeaways from the
pandemic well i think and it's not just
the pandemic i mean
the the the fortunate thing about the
pandemic is that it
it moves this center stage and gets
people talking about it
so i think um it demonstrated
that uh reliance on supply chains
uh a lot of which are
in countries who are not necessarily our
friends
is risky economically and risky
politically the question is
which stuff do we want to make in the
united states for what reasons
we want to make it in the united states
for industrial policy
and technological leadership and jobs
reasons
we want to make in the united states for
national security reasons and where do
we draw the line
take take up solar cells uh
america was once the leader in solar
solar panels
china basically undercut america's
pricing
stole a lot of technology they're now
the leader if we take it back
uh try to take it back with an
industrial policy
that means we're paying more money in
the short run for solar panels right
which
more expensive if we're trying to get
rid of carbon
so it's complicated you cannot settle
this at the level of grand theory
you have to have some basic norms we
want a positive sum
gain that helps american workers and
also helps the third world
and then you got to get very specific
yeah and often i think that
missing from the conversation where we
hear just this very
vague in general bring the production
back home
there's very little discussion of the
impact that that would have on the
prices of many of the things that we're
talking about as you point out with
solar panels which
is a decision that could be made i mean
the decision could be made here's a list
of 10 areas where
we believe it's worth paying more here's
how much
access would be reduced for the american
people as a result of that but we
believe it's worth it
well and by the way this is what japan
and korea
and china all did at earlier stages of
their economic development
i mean a ricardian economist would have
said to the japanese
why in the world do you want to invest
in an auto industry or a steel industry
or a machine tool industry
because you can get it cheaper from the
united states and the japanese answer
was well it depends on what your time
horizon is
if your time horizon is this year yeah
but if your time horizon is 50 years or
100 years or a thousand years
we want that industry in our country
because that's good for our economic
growth and for our jobs
so you you can't just take a snapshot at
a point in time
and look at the china price look at the
u.s price and say oh well obviously
we got to buy from china so it really
it's
it's it's it's tricky it's complicated
and you've got to get
you've got to get into the details in
the particulars without question without
question we've been speaking with bob
cutner who's co-editor of the american
prospect
also chair at the heller school for
social policy and management
at brandeis university i really
appreciate your time today and your
insights
thanks so much for having me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
all right let's get into a breaking
story that
many in the audience will appreciate and
unfortunately some in the audience will
be furious
that i'm even talking about this there
are
new kremlin papers which
appear to show vladimir putin's plot
to put donald trump in the white house
important this doesn't mean that trump
and putin
met to concoct this plan
or that trump was directly involved
the poll point is what has been said all
along for people who love to say russia
gate russia gate russia gate
that russia had a preference for trump
because of the cartoonish and
destabilizing nature that his presidency
would have
and they worked to help him regardless
of what trump knew or participated in
documents suggest russia launched
secret multi-agency effort to interfere
in u.s democracy
go by what is said not by what you
imagine i am saying and want to refute
the report vladimir putin personally
authorized
a secret spy agency operation to support
a quote mentally unstable donald trump
in the 2016 u.s presidential election
during a closed session of russia's
national security council
according to what are assessed to be
leaked kremlin documents
the key meeting took place on january
22nd 2016
with the russian president his spy
chiefs and senior ministers all present
they agreed a trump white house would
help secure moscow's strategic
objectives among them social turmoil in
the u.s
and a weakening of the american
president's negotiating position
how could anyone be surprised by this
put for all the people who say david you
love to criticize putin
putin's brilliant putin's brilliant
russia is brilliant at this
of course if you're russia you china and
the us
are the three major superpowers vying
for
the next decade or two of supremacy
among that that group of three what
could do more damage to the united
states
than electing a cartoonish [ __ ] like
donald trump
russia's smart i'm not criticized of
course
they tried to do this and unfortunately
the republican electorate
and subsequently enough of the
electorate that voted in the general
election
uh fell for it and trump won
it doesn't mean trump and putin met to
plan this
that's not how intelligence operations
work russia's three spy agencies were
ordered to find
practical ways to support trump in a
decree
appearing to bear putin's signature
these are the documents believed to now
be
be
authenticated by this point trump was
the front-runner in the republican
party's nomination race
a report prepared by putin's expert
department recommended moscow use all
possible force to ensure a trump victory
this is also relevant
because those saying well putin was
involved
even during the primary increasingly it
looks like
trump surfaced to the top of the
republican primary
thanks just to the ignorance of the
republican electorate that votes in the
primary
at that point at which it seemed that
trump was in the commanding position
that's when russia got the idea hey it
would be real imagine the laughing stock
that the u.s would be
if donald trump defeated hillary clinton
whatever your thoughts are about hillary
clinton
uh western intelligence agencies are
understood to have been aware of the
documents for some months
and to have carefully examined them the
papers seen by the guardian
seem to represent a serious and highly
unusual leak
from within the kremlin let me propose
something to you
okay this is this is speculation this
that's what we do this is an opinion
show i want to just
float an idea there seems to be
agreement
that these documents are legitimate and
there seems to be
agreement that this high-level leak from
the kremlin
is unusual okay i'm just going to float
something here
uh recently joe biden and vladimir putin
met and as far as we believe
earlier even more recently joe biden and
vladimir putin
spoke believed to be related to cyber
attacks
i'm just asking is it possible is it
possible
that part of the negotiation that took
place
was that uh on the one hand
biden would resist a counter-attack
shutting down a russian oil pipeline
and in exchange in exchange
some documents would leak from the
kremlin which rarely happens
which would illuminate exactly this
about russia's preference and work to
help donald trump
i don't know and the really funny part
about that
is that there's this idea that trumpists
have about how you project power as a
leader
that comes from trump's cartoonish
nature
you push aside the montenegrin president
or president but the prime minister
i believe president um and you talk in a
certain way
and you say certain things about kim
jong-un and putin or whatever
the real way that power actually works
is you don't stomp around and scream
like a child like trump does
it's by direct uh undisclosed
calls uh uh where you you say to a
leader hey this
this is how it has to be if you want
this then you have to do that
um and it it's just an idea because it
is unusual that such documents would
leak from the kremlin so
is there anything surprising here no
there really isn't no this is
this is everything we believed uh and
that made simply logical sense
um and uh that is uh that that is what
it is now of course not surprisingly the
kremlin is responding dismissively
putin's spokesman dmitry peskov says the
idea that russian leaders met and agreed
to support trump in early 2016 is a
great pulp fiction
the report number 3204 vd
is classified as secret it says trump is
the most promising candidate from the
kremlin's point of view
um there's a brief psychological
assessment of trump who's described as
an impulsive mentally unstable and
unbalanced
individual who suffers from an
inferiority complex
there is also apparent confirmation that
the kremlin
possesses compromi or potentially
compromising material on trump
collected the document says from trump's
earlier non-official visits to russian
federation territory
the paper refers to certain events that
happened during trump's trips to moscow
security council members are invited to
find details in appendix 5.
at paragraph 5 the document states it's
unclear what the appendix
contains it is acutely necessary to use
all possible force to facilitate his
election to the post of
u.s president so nothing surprising of
course there are people who are going to
say this is also part of the lie
but you know for for me this has always
been there's not going to be any smoking
gun of trump and putin meeting anybody
who's expecting that anybody who was
even expecting the russia stuff to lead
to trump's removal
as you can go back to april of 2017
where i say that's the wrong expectation
that's not how it works that's not
that's not what this
is uh but the clear motivation for
russia
to make the u.s a cartoonish laughing
stock by helping trump
it's obvious it would be weird if russia
didn't do it because it's such an
obvious intelligence opportunity many
countries
would think of it but wouldn't have the
know-how or the means to carry it out
russia's really good at getting
themselves involved in this stuff that's
the
that's the reality okay one other
similar story about new reporting that
we have
earlier this week i told you about the
forthcoming book
i alone can fix it by washington post
reporters
carol leonig and philip rucker and
during the week there have been little
leaks about what is in that book
there is now a new york magazine report
with more information about what's in it
and also some cnn reports and what is in
this book
is absolutely and totally wild
let's first look at some cnn published
quotes from the book
starting with donald trump talking about
the german chancellor angela merkel you
know joe biden today
is meeting with angela merkel and we'll
be doing a press conference with her my
sense is that uh biden's perspective on
merkel is different than trump's
uh donald trump reportedly said in the
oval office
quote that [ __ ] merkel as well as
i know the effing krauts
and i was raised by the biggest crowd
of them all kraut of course a pejorative
for german people trump reportedly
referring to the chancellor as that
[ __ ]
merkel also reported in this book
uh general mark milley was worried about
how do we protect the inauguration
and millie uh reportedly uh uh
said quote here's the deal guys these
guys are nazis
they're boogaloo boys they're proud boys
these are the same people we fought in
world war
ii and then lastly from cnn's reporting
on quotes
from the book i alone can fix it nancy
pelosi
uh reportedly saying of trump after
january 6th
this guy's crazy he's dangerous
he's a maniac we have deep
concerns the new york magazine report
outlining that mark milley said trump
preached quote the gospel of the fuhrer
referring to adolf hitler general mark
milley the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff
likened donald trump's effort to hold on
to power after the 2020 election to
adolf hitler
saying the president was preaching the
gospel of the fuhrer
with his lies about the election being
stolen according to
the book i alone can fix it by carol
leonig and philip rucker
the pentagon's top general said shortly
before the january sixth insurrection
that trump had led the country to the
brink of its own
reichstag moment viewing him as a
potential threat to the american
democracy
it seems very clear that mark milley uh
uh
you know what you actually know what's
really funny about this
was it last week or the week before that
we had that clip of mark milley
saying during a hearing hey guys listen
um
just because you learn about critical
race theory
doesn't mean you become some kind of
cartoon woke
character in the same way that mark
milley said
we are a university at the military and
we want to learn about marxism we want
to learn about communism we want to
learn about critical race theory we want
to understand
what are the beliefs of people within
the country and outside of it it's
it's quite clear you know whatever you
want to think about mark milly
that the fact that he's a student of
history has served him quite well
in being able to look at the at the past
and find situations that are analogous
to what we saw under donald trump
the article points out trump had
appointed millie to be chairman of the
joint chiefs in 2018
over the objection of defense secretary
james mattis
the army general's tenure at the top of
the pentagon at the top of the pentagon
had been relatively quiet until last
summer
when he appeared in uniform during an
infamous photo op for trump in lafayette
square
that followed the clearing of protesters
in front of the white house
millie apologized for creating a
perception of the military
involved in domestic politics
although the book chronicles millie's
concerns with trump dating back to that
moment
the general's worries grew rapidly as
trump plunged the nation into chaos
following election day
seven days later millie got a call from
quote an old friend
with an explicit warning that trump and
his allies were trying to overturn the
government
millie was confident that any attempts
by trump to hold on to power would be
thwarted
because the military wouldn't go along
they may try but they're not going to
effing succeed he told aids you can't do
this without the military
you can't do this without the cia and
fbi we're
the guys with the guns still millie was
disturbed by the sight of trump
supporters rallying to his cause in
november
calling them brown shirts in the streets
leonigan rucker wrote that millie
believed trump was stoking unrest
possibly in hopes of an excuse
to invoke the insurrection act and call
out the military
even at that high level there was the
fear
that that's what donald trump wanted to
do a key difference
between trump's dictatorial delusions
and those of adolf hitler
trump is in his mid-70s hitler was in
his 40s when the reichstag burned uh
trump could still get a good run if he
were re-elected in 24 right but uh it is
a different situation in that sense
significant significantly different age
i actually am looking forward to this
book i alone can fix it
normally i'm not big on these books but
this one i do plan to read
listen um today's voicemail kind of bums
me out
it's about cuba and we talk sometimes
about the revolutionary left
it's a sort of pseudo-populism on the
left which sometimes blinds people
to authoritarianism and the lack of
progressivism in authoritarianism where
they end up
supporting uh these you know
often military uniform wearing faux
populists
and i've been talking this week about
how the u.s has
some blame for the situation in cuba
thanks to the
hypocritical and counterproductive u.s
embargo of cuba
i want the embargo to be dropped i don't
want american involvement in cuban
politics and yet
i cannot as a progressive support
something as authoritarian
as the castro regime which came to power
in 1959
handed power from brother to brother in
2008. that's not progressive that's just
not progressive
and sadly i did get a voicemail it's
very long i'll only play some of it
from a revolutionary leftist who doesn't
like my perspective take a listen
david i'm really disappointed in you the
way you're framing cuba
politically you are purposefully leaving
out to full context but il castro did
not start
out as a dictator nor a dictator wannabe
so first of all didn't start out as a
dictator conceding that that's
eventually what he became
okay he was a reaction to the batista
regime
friendly to the united states corporate
industrial oligarchy
the people in cuba up rose because they
were sick and tired of
being paid lousy wages sure they didn't
want to be served for the american
industrial machine okay
fidel castro i believe he was educated
in the united states
and so he had a little bit one-up on his
fellow cubans
and he made sure that they understood
the true nature of what was going
on listen this is how faux populist
authoritarians work
the fact that castro came to power
in a context where there was genuine
real in the streets dissatisfaction with
cuban leadership
doesn't change the fact that this is how
faux populism works it's the populist
rhetoric
and next thing you know the same guy's
in power
for 49 years with a police state
with complete and total control over
every aspect of the people
and and of the economy the fact that
castro replaced
something bad and that those who were
protesting
in the 50s in cuba did so genuinely and
for good reasons
doesn't mean that we praise fidel castro
in power since 1959
until 2008 at which point he hands power
to his brother
it's not progressive i can't support it
and this is you know it's a very similar
playbook to venezuela
because in the 50s there were reasons to
protest
doesn't mean we now don't criticize
what is an authoritarian regime even the
military uniforms
similar between you know the castro
green uniform and hugo chavez and
nicolas maduro in venezuela
appearing sometimes in you know
essentially military dress uniforms
and it's sort of disturbing to me that
supposed progressives not only fall for
the faux populist rhetoric
but they even fall for like the even the
military uniform stuff doesn't raise
alarms to you the suspicion
that these folks have of the military
uniform
when it's the u.s or the uk military it
seems to go out the window
when you see the same sort of stuff
being done
in cuba and in venezuela i will never
get it and again
i've at this point i've done this so
many times when i do these political
uh compass type tests i am not
an authoritarian leftist i'm a small
libertarian leftist so
i can't as a progressive support
authoritarian regimes and it makes me
sad when
when people who sometimes think of
themselves as progressive support that
it's just disappointing we have a great
bonus show for you today
sign up at jointpacman.com uh we'll see
you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman